-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy and Golden Glob
Award-winning actress
you know from films such a
"Us" and "The Invisible Man"
and television shows such as
"The West Wing" and "Mad Men."
She stars as June Osborne
in "The Handmaid's Tale,"
which returns
for its fourth-season premiere
tonight on Hulu.
Please welcome back to sho
Elisabeth Moss.
It's so nice to see you,
Lizzie!
-Hi. How are you?
It's so good to see you.
-You were here right befor
everything came to a stop,
and you were on your way.
We were talking
about last February.
You were on your way to start.
I imagine you got
a fair bit delayed.
-Yes. We got a tad delayed
About six months.
Yeah. Just a small
six-month delay. Yeah.
-And then did you --
You looped back and you actually
came back to New York where yo
had to spend an extended amoun
of time for a long period
of your life, right?
-Yeah, I live in New York,
and it was the longest amoun
of time I think I've spent her
in one chunk
since, like, I was unemploye
in my early 20s.
[ Laughter ]
-Probably --
I was going to say, you know
it must be nice now to not b
unemployed, but this last year
I feel like all of us
felt like --
"Oh, if only to be
unemployed and outside."
-[ Laughs ] I know.
Exactly, exactly.
It wasn't exactly the brea
I would have loved.
-You spent some time --
Couple of cats?
-Yes, I spent some time
with my cats, Lucy and Ethel
Thank you so much
for mentioning them.
-Were they good roommates?
-They're great roommates.
Fantastic. They're the best.
They're very low-maintenance
-I want to compliment you
because, you know, one of
the things I think everybody
is doing now is looking back and
seeing what they accomplishe
during this last year.
You started a production
company. Well done.
-Yeah, I did. Thank you.
I tried to keep myself
as busy as possible.
And it was one of things
I'd wanted to do for many years,
and I finally kind of had th
time to invest in such a thing
So I keep getting asked, like,
"Did you pick up a hobby?"
Like, "What did you do?
Did you start cooking?
Did you start knitting?"
And, no, I opened up a company
-Well done. Like I said,
it's very impressive.
-Thank you.
-I feel this way every tim
"Handmaid's" come back
because I watch this show.
I love this show.
And yet I feel like I forget
and someone is like,
"Oh, my God!
I'm so happy it's back!"
And then I start watching.
And this picks up exactly
where we left off,
and, once again, life's
not great for the handmaids.
-No, no.
Life's just --
Life is just not great.
That's what comes
with being a handmaid, Seth.
Just the basic job itself.
-Yup.
-Not great.
-Right. It's not like,
"Good news! We joined a union!
[ Laughter ]
-"Guess what!
We've made some changes."
-"Yeah, we got --
It's really great.
We all --
Three weeks paid vacation.
Which is huge for handmaids.
-You still have to do that
whole, like, monthly rate thing,
but, you know, besides that...
[ Laughter ]
-You --
It's very difficult --
and we discussed a lot --
trying to find
a clip for the show.
-Yes.
-But you don't want the give
too much away in a clip,
and it was hard to find one,
and I want to thank you becaus
you sort of worked overtim
to select something
from this season
that doesn't give too much away.
-Yeah,
it's very, very difficult.
It's also, obviously,
a dark show,
so you have to pick
the right thing.
And you guys have a 30-second,
you know, maximum,
which is almost impossible
but I think I did my best
in finding something
that I feel communicates
what this season is about.
-All right. Let's take a loo
at what Lizzie brought.
-[ Laughing ]
-How dare you.
People tune in to this sho
for spoilers.
-I feel like -- I feel lik
that's a win-win situation
You know what I mean?
Like, people get to see
a beautiful cat.
Ethel with some "Late Night"
exposure, which is good.
-Now, how does Lucy
feel about the fact
that Ethel got in the clip
and she was not to be seen
-To be fair, because I'm a goo
cat mom, I sent two clips.
I sent one of Lucy
and one of Ethel.
And I left it up to you guys
so I'm safe in this house.
-Oh, sure. That's the stor
you'll tell Lucy.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, honey,
there were two clips."
-"It wasn't my fault.
They just picked the other one
I don't know what to tell you.
-What about -- You directe
three episodes this year.
You directed one in the past
Or was this the first time
-No, no.
-Oh, wow.
This is the first time
I directed, yeah,
and I was supposed to
just direct the first --
episode three,
and then I ended up directin
three episodes
during a pandemic.
-Was that basically
sort of due to
"Hey, it might be easier
if we had fewer people aroun
as supposed to..."
-Definitely, definitely.
It was definitely helpful
as a production
to have less people,
and people liked the
first episode that I did,
so I kind of just
put myself up for the job.
-It looks like the pandemi
has been pretty good
for Lizzie Moss.
-[ Laughs ]
Why do you sound so mad?
-How did you find it?
How did you enjoy the directing?
-I loved it. I loved it.
It was incredibly fulfilling
It was, honestly,
the most rewarding thing I think
I've ever done in my career.
I loved it so much.
My favorite thing
was working with the actors,
and they're so, so incredible,
and I developed something
that I really loved doing,
which was the
complete objectification
of Max Minghella,
who plays Nick.
-Yeah, so, explain
the subjectification.
-Well, I think he's --
You know, he's a beautiful man
-Right.
-He's a beautiful man.
And, you know,
there's no denying that.
And I just wanted to sort of
flip the tables on things.
And -- I mean, look at him
-Lot of close-ups
when it was left to you.
-When it was left in my hands,
me and my cinematographer,
Stuart Biddlecombe,
designed scenes and shots
to highlight his beauty
and, you know, things on -
close-ups on his eyes
and things
on the back of his neck.
-Yeah, we noticed you were -
And I will say --
I heard you had said
he had a really nice neck.
And I thought,
"Who has a nice neck?"
And then I saw this. I'm like,
"Guy's got a good neck."
-It's a beautiful neck.
-It's a really good neck.
-And Stuart and I would si
behind the monitor,
and we're supposed to be
very serious and watching this
really serious scene,
and we'd just be sitting there
and be like, "Oh, God.
Isn't he beautiful?
Look at him. Look at him.
He's so handsome.
Look at those eyebrows.
God, he's good."
-One of the things that happened
between the third
and the fourth season
is Margaret Atwood
had the book "The Testaments
come out,
which takes place in the futur
but in the same world.
Some of the same characters.
-You read.
Which is awesome.
-Yeah, I read. I loved.
And it's interesting
because, sort of knowing
the future of this timeline,
you know, it allows you
to look at the characters
slightly differently.
How much did you guys
take that book into accoun
in the creation of the seaso
which, of course,
is still far before
the events of that book?
-Totally. I mean,
Margaret did us a solid,
and she put it 15 years ahead,
which allows us to kind of
create our own story
getting there.
But it is really cool knowin
kind of --
especially maybe somebody
like Aunt Lydia.
I don't want to spoil anything
for anybody
who hasn't read the book,
but, you know, Ann and I
worked a lot together
this season as actors
and as director-actor,
and we were able to take
what we kind of know is coming
and bring it into the season
for the more eagle-eyed viewer
or viewers
who have read that book.
So it has been
extremely informative.
I mean, if anyone could writ
the end of your story,
it should be Margaret Atwood
-That is true.
I think we're all lucky
that that happened.
And I'm so -- I genuinely am
very happy the show is back.
-Thank you.
-It continues to be such
an accomplishment,
and hopefully we'll see yo
next time here in the studio
-Absolutely, absolutely.
I'd love to see you in person.
-All the best, Lizzie.
The first three episodes
of "The Handmaid's Tale"
are available now on Hulu.